let's bring in bishop td jakes he always
saves the day he's considered one of the
most influential spiritual leaders in
our nation
a senior pastor of the potter's house in
dallas his voice is heard in millions of
homes every single day
he also by the way is a film producer or
grammy award winner and a best-selling
author
his newest book is called when women
pray
ten women of the bible who change their
world through prayer
bishop td jakes joins us first on cbs
this morning always good to see you
bishop jakes
so in the book good morning it's a
pleasure to be with you good morning
in the book you say winston churchill
says when you go through hell keep going
you say when you're going through hell
keep praying and you're focusing on
women
why
this is a critical time for women
they're up to bad in so many different
ways
uh whether they're in the board rooms or
the courtrooms or whether they're in the
legislature or
managing an office or managing getting
kids off to school
more and more pressure and more and more
responsibility
is placed on them and particularly at
this time when we're facing so many
crises in the world
uh i wanted to call us back to prayer
and
an inner introspective look at how to
survive the vicissitudes of life
yeah because you said prayer is needed
now more than ever because americans are
grieving
what do you mean well we've had over 200
000 people to die we've had millions of
people to be contracted with this virus
where many of them have not recovered
well
uh we're grieving because our our
notions about our country and ourself
have been shattered we're grieving
because of
violence crime police brutality
racial discord the economy's shaking
losing our jobs it's a whole list of
things
that have caused us regardless to what
you think about the particulars of those
things
is still stressful on either side of the
argument
you were talking about sarah sarah's
story was fascinating to me because you
said
god's ability to act is not dependent on
your ability
to pray you were saying you don't have
to be religious to pray what do you mean
because most people think well
how do you pray with you if you're not
religious yeah
well you know the thing about it is we
come to god we think we have to be
sanctimonious
old thou which ruleth in heaven and
earth you it's a conversation it's a
relationship
it's less religious it's more relational
and i think that we need to demystify
the art of prayer by understanding
you're having a conversation
you're easing some of the pressure
you're dumping on some of the load
you're getting the stress off of
yourself and recognizing that there's
somebody bigger than you
is comforting at a time where we have
little to trust in
that is stable and solid in the times
we're living in right now
you know you came to us in march when
covert was first starting
certainly you didn't think that we would
still be talking about this as we're
heading into october
and in the book you talk about the loss
for you your church your community and
funerals
being able to preside over funerals i
thought with could you explain what you
mean by that
it was it is in fact uh very stressful
and very difficult
uh we're designed to want to comfort
families to be there when they're
grieving
uh our church does about 400 funerals a
year that number has escalated
uh the tragedies the atrocities the
families who
are grieving because they couldn't be
with their loved ones when they died
uh the limitations on the funerals
everyone in bass nobody can touch
anybody
you can't give them a hug sometimes it's
not so much what we say
when people are hurting you can't even
you can't even hug a bereaved wife or
children it's a very very difficult time
and then
the other thing i want to quickly know
particularly in the african-american
community
sometimes there are people in our
community that the only time that they
really get to really express
their appreciation and they they only
get to be important at a funeral
and when you lose that you've lost a lot
and i've lost your earpiece
um you've lost a lot and that that
really kind of is demoralizing
it increases the grief process and the
guilt
process of not being able to be with
them and hold them
and help them yeah that's such an
important point you say when women pray
they find
hope and joy in unexpected places but
there's also room for men too
you're not leaving the men out of this
conversation
no i i started out with the women
because there are a lot of men today
that are where they are because of the
prayers of their mothers and
grandmothers
wives and daughters but it does not
exclude men from prayer in fact the
bible is very open about men not to
always pray without
ceasing and really though i use 10 women
i think men will find inspiration in
those pages too
all right bishop td jakes always good to
have you here thank you sir
when women pray thank you for having me
always
when women pray is on sale today
wherever you like to buy your books